so this will be the second video on the
series on endocrinology make sure to
watch the first video in this series in
which we discussed about the overview of
the human endocrine system we talked
about the type of the receptors the
types of hormones
we also discussed in brief about some of
the important endocrine organs like the
thyroid parathyroid and the adrenal
glands and the next important organ to
discuss in the human in ukraine' system
is the pancreas the pancreas consists of
a both endocrine and an exocrine part
the exocrine part of the pancreas
secretes important digestive enzymes
into the duodenum whereas the endocrine
part of the pancreas secretes two
important hormones the insulin and the
glucose on they also secrete
somatostatin which is of lesser
importance
pancreatic islets also known as the
islands of Langerhans are irregularly
shaped patches of endocrine tissue that
are present in the tail of pancreas that
contain different types of cells like
the alpha cells beta cells and the Delta
cells out of these the alpha cells
secrete glucagon the beta cells secrete
insulin whereas the Delta cells produce
another hormone this rahmato statin now
insulin has a wide range of effects on
metabolisms of glucose are the
carbohydrates proteins as well as fats
whenever we eat there is a rise in the
blood glucose concentration which is
detected by the pancreas causing the
release of insulin the overall effect of
insulin is to decrease the concentration
of glucose in the blood by stimulating
the uptake of glucose into the cells and
also by the conversion of glucose into
glycogen which is the storage form in
the liver now it is known as an anabolic
hormone which is just opposite of
catabolic since it prevents the
breakdown of both fats proteins in the
body
glucagon on the other hand works just
opposite to that of insulin see the
hormone glucagon is mainly released when
glucose is gone from the body meaning a
low concentration of glucose in the
blood the glucose causes breakdown of
glycogen to glucose in the liver which
is known as glycogenolysis it also
causes the conversion of proteins amino
acids and fats into glucose which is
known as gluconeogenesis the overall
effect is to increase the blood glucose
concentration
now we will take a brief look at the
reproductive hormones in males we have
the testes and in the females we have
the ovaries these canards produce
important hormones without which a
reproduction is not possible the male
gonads the testes produce important
hormones like testosterone inhibin and d
mullerian hormone and some other
androgens like androstenedione
and dihydrotestosterone these hormones
are essential for the formation of
sperms and development of secondary
sexual characteristics the ovaries which
secrete two important hormones the
estrogens and the progesterones the
estrogens are of various types most
abundantly found in the females is the
estradiol and also others like East Iran
and Eastern East region causes the
development of sex organs like uterus
fallopian tubes vagina cervix it also
causes the development of secondary
sexual character progesterone on the
other hand mainly acts on the uterus
cervix and vagina and prepares these
organs for conception of the zygote it
also affects metabolisms and also
affects the body temperature so we have
all these endocrine glands all over the
body that secrete these various hormones
but the secretion from these glands
required control which is provided by
two important endocrine glands located
in your brain the hypothalamus and the
pituitary gland the hypothalamus is a
small almond sized part of the brain
that lies below the thalamus and
controls a wide variety of body
functions to maintain a proper body's
internal environment these functions
include regulation of body temperature
hunger sleep thirst and many other
things and one of the most important
things that the hypothalamus does is
that it links the nervous system to the
endocrine system through the pituitary
gland to understand this we can compare
the hypothalamus to a vital part of the
brain that is able to sense the various
conditions or processes that are going
around in the body
now it controls many aspects of the body
through the autonomic nervous system but
it also controls a body's endocrine
response through the pituitary gland
secretions so if we take a look at the
pituitary gland it is composed of an
anterior lobe and a posterior lobe and
together they secrete about eight
hormones which either inhibit or
stimulate secretions from other
endocrine glands the hypothalamus
directly or indirectly controlled the
secretions from the pituitary gland the
posterior pituitary is simple it does
not secrete hormones from its own but in
reality these hormones are actually
synthesized in the hypothalamus the
hypothalamus has two important
collections of neurons known as the
Supra optic and the paraventricular
nucleus the paraventricular nucleus
secretes oxytocin whereas the supraoptic
nucleus secretes vasopressin or the
antidiuretic hormone these axons of the
neurons that directly leads the
posterior pituitary and secrete these
hormones there and then these hormones
are released into the blood circulation
and carried all over the body oxytocin
is a peptide hormone that mainly acts on
two important places in the body the
uterus and the breast in the uterus it
causes powerful smooth muscle
contractions which are essential for
childbirth and impress it is essential
for lactation visible present also known
as the antidiuretic hormone is also a
peptide hormone vasopressin mainly acts
on two important places the kidneys and
the blood vessels in the kidneys the
vasopressin causes a reabsorption of
water and decreases the urine output in
the blood vessels the vasopressin causes
constriction of blood vessels increases
peripheral vascular resistance and thus
increasing the blood pressure so now
when we take a look at the anterior
pituitary things are a bit different the
anterior lobe of pituitary produces six
important hormones the secretions of
which are directly controlled by
releasing or inhibiting hormones that
are produced inside the hypothalamus the
hormones that are produced in the
hypothalamus release the pituitary
through blood vessel and in response to
these releasing hormones the pituitary
gland then produces hormones that
control the secretion of other endocrine
glands to take this into context
let's take the example when the
hypothalamus releases the hormone
thyrotropin-releasing hormone or the trh
from the hypothalamus it is carried to
the pituitary through the blood vessels
which causes the release of another
hormone the thyroid stimulating hormone
from the pituitary the TSH then acts on
the thyroid gland and causes the release
of important thyroid hormones in a
similar way the hypothalamus releases
CRH or the corticotropin-releasing
hormone which causes a release of ACTH
from pedia tree or the
adrenocorticotropic hormone the ACTH
then acts on the adrenals causing the
release of important adrenal hormones
similarly we have the
gonadotropin-releasing hormone or the
GnRH the GnRH acts on the periodic azam
release of follicle stimulating hormone
and luteinizing hormone from pituitary
gland
these hormones act on the gonads causing
the release of sex hormones similarly we
have the growth hormone releasing
hormone from the hypothalamus which
causes the release of growth hormone
from the pituitary gland the growth
hormone acts on almost all the cells of
the body dopamine is released from the
hypothalamus which inhibits the
secretion of prolactin the dopamine
basically inhibits the release of
prolactin from the pituitary gland so
this was a brief overview about the
human into crane system guys thank you
so much for watching this video if you
found this video and all the other free
educational videos on this channel
helpful you can now support meThe
simplified on patreon.com for literally
the price of a coffee cup this will
allow me to fund my work and make more
videos like this and will also unlock
some cool patreon only exclusive content
like behind the scenes of these videos
upcoming videos early notifications and
exclusive flash cards and handouts make
sure to subscribe us on YouTube for all
the upcoming videos and also make sure
to follow us on Instagram and Facebook
for flashcards notifications and much
more